An electrician has the following
lengths of cable: 23
inches, 49 inches, and 8 feet.
How much cable does
he have in Feet?
So these are the lengths.
Each of these are the
length of a cable in
inches, inches, and feet.
And we want to know the total
length, if you add all of
these up, and we need the
total length in feet.
And so the best way to do that
is to convert each of these
lengths into feet, and
then add them all up.
So let's start with this one
right over here: 23 inches.
So it's always important to
have your intuition give a
little bit of a check on what
the answer should look like.
There are many inches per foot,
so when you convert this
into feet, you should have
a smaller number.
There are 12 inches per foot.
So this should be
a small number.
This is not even 2 feet.
24 inches would be 2 feet.
So this should be less
than 2 feet.
But let's do it mathematically.
So to do it mathematically, we
want this inches to cancel out
with inches.
And the way you do that,
is you put that in the
denominator.
So it cancels out
with the inches.
And so we want feet per inches,
or foot per inches.
I guess I'll just write ft.
It could be feet or
foot, singular or
plural, it doesn't matter.
So how many feet are
there per inches?
Or another way to think about
it, how many inches
are there per foot?
1 foot is equal to 12 inches,
or you could say 1 foot for
every 12 inches, or you could
read this as 1/12
of a foot per inch.
Either way, if we multiply this,
the inches cancel out.
That's why we know, at least
mathematically, if we just did
it mechanically, why we
shouldn't multiply by 12.
But also it should make
complete sense.
We should be dividing by 12
because when you express this
distance in feet, it should be a
smaller number, so we should
divide by 12.
So what does this give us?
This is equal to 23
times 1 is 23/12.
This inches cancels out with
that inches, and we're just
left with feet.
So that is 23/12 feet.
And this is an improper
fraction, but I'll leave it as
an improper fraction for now
because they're actually
easier to manipulate
than mixed numbers.
So that's that first cable.
Let's do the second one
right here: 49 inches.
So the second cable
is 49 inches, and
we do the same thing.
We want to convert it to feet.
We have inches in
the denominator.
We should end up dividing by
something because we want a
smaller number.
49 inches will be a smaller
number of feet
by a factor of 12.
So what we care about is feet
per inches, and we know that
there is 1 foot for every
12 inches, or 1/12
of a foot per inch.
It can be read either way.
When you multiply, the inches
will cancel out, and we will
be left with 49 times 1, which
is 49, over 12 feet.
That is the second cable.
And then we have this
last cable right
here, this 8-foot cable.
The very last one is 8 feet, and
if we want, we can convert
that into an improper
fraction.
At this point, there's two
ways we can do it.
Everything is in feet.
Here, it's improper fractions.
We could, if we want, convert
these into mixed numbers and
then add them up, or we can
convert this into an improper
fraction that has the same
denominator, and
then add them up.
And the easiest way, I think, is
to just have this with the
denominator 12.
So 8 feet is the same thing
as what over 12?
Well, what's 8 times 12?
It's 96, right?
96 divided by 12 is 8.
8 is the same thing as 96/12.
These are equivalent.
Let me make sure this 8 and
96/12 is the exact same thing.
I picked 12 because these have
12 in the denominator.
And then I said, 12
times 8 is 96.
So 8 feet is the same
thing as 96/12 feet.
And now I can add
everything up.
The total length of cable he has
is-- I'll do it over here.
It's 96/12 plus 23/12 plus
49/12, and everything is in
feet, so this answer will
give us in feet.
We have all of the same
denominators.
Our denominator is 12.
And so our numerator's going
to be 96 plus 23 plus 49.
Let's add that up over here.
So 96, 23, 49, we have
to add it up.
6 plus 3 is 9.
9 plus 9 is 18.
1 plus 9 is 10.
10 plus 2 is 12.
12 plus 4 is 16.
So that's 168.
So this expression right here is
equal to 168/12, which is a
valid answer.
And, of course, all of
these are in feet,
so it's 168/12 feet.
But let's write this now as a
mixed number, so that we have
a better idea of really
how many feet it is.
And to do that, we just
divide 168 by 12.
So 12 goes into 168.
It doesn't go into 1.
It goes into 16 exactly
one time.
1 times 12 is 12.
We subtract.
16 minus 12 is 4.
Bring down the 8.
12 goes into 48 four times.
4 times 12 is 48.
And we have no remainder.
So 168/12 is exactly
14, so this is
exactly equal to 14 feet.
So our electrician has exactly
14 feet of cable.